-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "the Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today is Monday.
-Wow.
-Happy Monday.
Today is Cyber Monday.
Yeah.
I love shopping on Cyber Monday,
'cause nothing beats spending
the holiday season
on hold with the Bank of America
fraud department.
[ Laughter ]
"Huh?
No, I didn't buy a TV from
Walmart in the Philippines.
No, that wasn't me."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, over 60 million people
bought gifts today,
yet somehow, on Christmas, all
we do is exchange gift cards.
How does that work?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But it was a big day.
Amazon offered tons of deals,
Target rolled out
major discounts,
and RadioShack was like, "We
should really get a website."
[ Laughter ]
"We should do that.
Maybe next year.
Make a note."
Yep, most people
prefer online shopping
because it's easier
and because we're tired of
having to sadly raise our hand
at the self-checkout machines.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm an adult who needs help.
Thanks."
[ Laughter ]
"Do I weigh my bag,
or give me the bag, and --
Just give me --
I'll buy two bags.
What is --"
[ Applause ]
"How did it know that I didn't
put the thing in the bag."
[ Laughter ]
What's going on?
Meanwhile, today, in Washington,
First Lady Jill Biden revealed
this year's
White House holiday decorations.
There are 41 Christmas trees
and almost 80,000 lights.
Meanwhile, the family
at 1602 Pennsylvania Avenue
is like, "They always
have to one-up us every year.
They gotta one-up."
The theme
of this year's decorations
is Gifts from the Heart.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
As opposed to today's theme,
Gifts I Found Online
for 60% Off.
[ Laughter ]
Kinda from the heart, yeah.
Yet there are 41 Christmas trees
in the White House,
and even former President Trump
made it onto
one of the ornaments.
This is real.
This is a real ornament.
Take a look at this.
You see him?
There he is.
[ Laughter ]
You know that's definitely
on the side of the tree
that faces the wall, you know?
[ Laughter ]
"You made that yourself?
Let me hang it up."
[ Applause ]
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
amazing, amazing.
It looks like a reindeer.
It looks just like you made a
reindeer out of pop sticks.
There you go, back there.
[ Laughter ]
'Course, the big news
that everyone is talking about
is this new COVID variant,
called omicron.
Yeah, we need another variant
like we another
turkey sandwich for lunch.
[ Laughter ]
Omicron.
It sounds like a Transformer
who can't smell or taste.
[ Laughter ]
"Omicron!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're getting kind of deep
in the Greek alphabet, you know?
Pretty soon, we're gonna
run out of letters
and just start using Gatorade
flavors, you know?
Fauci will be like,
"We have to do whatever it takes
to stop
the fierce melon variant."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, basically,
everyone is bummed out
about the new variant.
Meanwhile, Delta Airlines
is like, "Oh, yeah!
Hey-ya!
What's up?!
I knew we were gonna --
Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
But the White House
is trying to handle it today.
President Biden
held a press conference,
and he told Americans
that the new variant
is a cause for concern,
not a cause for panic.
Americans heard and were like,
"Well, in that case,
we'll just buy 10 pallets of
toilet paper instead of 12."
[ Laughter ]
But the White House said
it will take two weeks
to have definitive data
on the new strain.
That's right, even our COVID
information has shipping delays.
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable.
[ Applause ]
Of course -- [ Chuckles ]
Of course, Biden told everyone
to get their booster.
And he said
to carve out some time,
because rolling up your sleeves
takes longer than you think.
-Is the First Lady getting one,
as well, Mr. President?
-She's gonna get one.
I think she's teaching.
But she's gonna get one, yes.
-Mr. President
what do you say...
-What in the world?!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
At that point,
Just take your shirt off.
What are we --
What is going on?
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Never seen anything like it.
Some major business news.
Today, Jack Dorsey stepped down
as the CEO of Twitter.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yep.
Twitter hopes
that his replacement can find
new and exciting ways
for strangers
to say horrible things
to each other.
[ Laughter ]
I think Dorsey
made the right decision, though.
It seems like the job
really took a toll on him.
Here he is nine years ago.
That's him.
And here he is today.
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
Even Obama's like,
"Man, that job really aged you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's real.
I mean...
It's definitely a sign to leave
your job when you're 45
and you look like Tom Hanks
at the end of "Castaway."
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Some news from overseas.
Apparently, Kim Jong-un
banned leather coats
in North Korea
so that nobody
can copy his style.
[ Laughter ]
This is real.
Can we see him
in his leather jacket?
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
Right now, there's a giant
police raid in the sofa section
at Raymour & Flanigan.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this -- due to
a huge snowstorm in the U.K.,
more than 60 people, including
members of an Oasis cover band,
have been stuck in a pub
since Friday night.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
After three days,
everyone was fighting
with each other.
It was almost like
they were in the band Oasis.
[ Laughter ]
Almost.
And finally,
this is going viral.
Someone filmed a fellow driver
on the highway
with a Christmas tree
that might have been
just a bit too big
for their car.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-He was like,
"This is gonna look great
in my studio apartment."